[Music]
hello monkeys
the sails will serve my son Frieza and
obey his every command
how is scheduled at this is still in the
nursing capsule
my boy you bring honor to our name the
latent battle power within you astonish
me you find that the girlie in a pod and
sent him to a remote planet I'll raise
it to be a mighty warrior and one day I
will have my revenge I don't think we
can afford to wait
freezes up to something I'm sure of it
it's a perfect plan to get rid of the
Saiyans planet and all wouldn't you
agree
[Music]
[Applause]
hey everybody it's Charlie we got a
whole bunch of new Dragon Ball super to
break down we got a couple new plot
synopsis we have new details on
broglie's backstory how they've changed
that from the original Broly movie in a
whole bunch of old characters they
confirmed they're bringing back so if
you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos but
first big thing couple new clips that
they released with that bro Lee fight
with Goku and Vegeta when he first lands
on planet Earth and we did find out why
it is they come to Planet Earth it's
mostly about Frieza searching for the
Dragon Balls and team Goku searching for
them as well so that they can stop
Frieza so Frieza is the real villain of
the film even though bro Lee is gonna go
crazy on everyone all Hulk rage monster
style but here's the official new plot
synopsis so it starts out Goku and
Vegeta move as fast as possible to
recover the Dragon Balls and face their
new and permanent rival Frieza in the
formidable Broly the deadly battle
barely begins before broglie's
overwhelming power evolves during the
fight
so Goku and Vegeta are forced to go on
the defensive then he goes on to tell
broglie's new backstory it says 41 years
ago King Vegeta had a baby the king was
so proud of his latent ability is a
powerful warrior at the same time his
loyal military right-hand Paras also had
a baby called Broly he had a potential
even greater than Prince Vegeta so the
jealous King sent him to a dark far
planet in a space capsule you see that
all play out during the trailer Perry
gets furious at the betrayal of King
Vegeta philippson ghost the search
for bro Lee finds him but on their way
back they crash land on a foreign planet
and gets stuck there for 40 plus years
while they're away you get all these
scenes with King cult coming to meet the
sands for the first time before Frieza
decides to blow up the planet
there's no allusion to involvement from
beerus or any of the other gods of
destruction or anything like that this
all seems like it's largely freezes plan
to blow up the planet but before that
happens when you see King cold here you
see King Vegeta bowing to him all the
sands wearing Frieza force armor so it
seems like he means to use them as super
soldiers in the freeze of force but for
whatever reason maybe Frieza feels like
they're going to betray him at some
point
feels like it's better to get rid of the
sands than to keep them around so that's
where his plan to blow up the planet
comes from
cut to 40 plus years later a patrol from
the Frieza force with a couple of these
characters here that I'll explain in a
second find Pegasus and Broly there on
the edge of the galaxy they have no idea
what's happened they take the two of
them back to Freeza Freeza recognizing
how powerful Broly is strikes a bargain
with him and pair gets to become part of
a special team within the Frieza force
then eventually sends them to Planet
Earth in this Arctic area when a
Dragonball is detected so the whole
reason why Broly in this special ship
land here in this Arctic place is
because Frieza hears about a Dragonball
sends them to get it that's where they
run into Goku and Vegeta so I know the
big question is why do they all start
fighting because of that difference in
the backstory how they're sent away and
how para gus' still hates King Vegeta it
implies that Vegeta is the person that
Broly really wants to take down here not
Goku like during the original Broly
movie if you haven't seen it in a while
the whole reason why bro Lee wanted to
kill Goku is is because when they were
children next to each other in pods Goku
would cry it annoyed Broly and that's it
like that's the only motivation he has
so there's nowhere to go with this
character but up and changing his
backstory and motivation a little bit so
this new version just makes a little bit
more sense why he would want to go after
Vegeta because parry gets probably
filled his head with all that hate for
King Vegeta
he's the reason why we were banished son
because he didn't want you to outshine
his son so they run into each other
throwing down for the Dragonball then he
probably learns who Vegeta is gets
really mad things get really crazy but
then you also see him fighting Frieza
during the trailer obviously it's clear
that they learned the truth of freezes
deception and that's how you wind up
with the bro Lee versus everyone
scenario which is kind of where they
ended up in the original bro Lee movie
but the way they got there was a little
bit different you probably recognize
some familiar characters during those
flashbacks to King cold meeting the
sands for the first time too you see the
ginyu force
there's our Banda Doria there's a bunch
of new Frieza force characters they
introduced in present day as well some
of their names are kind of funny there's
barely bulu guess what he's named after
Lemmo you can guess what he's named
after this one is Chi Lai and this is
Kiko know they also clarified that it's
Lemmo and Chi lie that fire
Broly and Pegasus on that distant planet
they're the ones that bring them to
Frieza and induct them into the freezer
force did you soften the trailer they're
bringing back Bardock and Goku's mother
as you see them send him off in the pod
before the planet gets destroyed Raddatz
is also supposed to be coming back too
there was a big question that was raised
by another new promo because it teases
Broly has a future that goes beyond the
events of the Dragon Ball super movie
like they're not gonna kill him off at
the end so either that would continue in
whatever next Dragon Ball series they
end up doing or he could just show up in
future movies that they released they
haven't really said what's gonna happen
obviously they don't want to spoil the
end of the movie but it does imply that
he will survive so whatever it is they
do to bring him back down from legendary
Super Saiyan level and keep him from
destroying planet Earth it's not going
to be killing him normal rules of a
drama like this like a full character
arc would be Vegeta apologizing for what
his father did I'm sorry my father
banished you para g'sten Broly accepting
his apology then Frieza being held
accountable for the destruction of their
homeworld so like I said Frieza seems
like the true big bad of the film even
though all the promos and the trailers
are selling this is a Goku vs. Broly
fight but let me know in the comments
what do you want them to do with the bro
league character after the events of
this movie do you want them to include
him in the next series or do you just
want them to hold him for any future
movies that they do there was also an
interesting question I saw someone
asking on one of my other Dragon Ball
videos about what's gonna happen when
Disney finishes buying outfox they get
all their intellectual property in
because Fox was the last person to make
that live-action Dragon Ball movie does
that mean that Disney now gets the
live-action Dragon Ball rights and would
they try to make another live-action
movie even though I feel like that would
be a terrible idea like just do not even
attempt that the only really successful
stuff Disney has released that's based
on anime properties are Ghibli films
that are all Miyazaki and in those cases
Disney didn't have any creative input on
that it's just Ghibli making a film then
giving the distribution rights to Disney
so Disney slaps their label on it but
they don't have any hand in making any
of that in none of it is live-action so
what they might do behind the scenes is
just haggle for certain distribution
rights because right now Funimation
films is releasing the Dragon Ball super
in theaters in North America this gonna
be January 16th is being released in
December inside Japan so if you speak
Japanese you can go fly there and watch
the movie a little bit before everyone
else but if you live in another country
just be sure to check your local
listings it'll probably be sometime
around the middle of January in your
country while you wait for everything
click here for my other Dragon Ball
super movie trailer and click here to
learn what's happening with Hawkeye
after Avengers 4 thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]